SORRY.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
♪♪♪
>>> SARAH, PLEASE?
SARAH, PLEASE OPEN THE DOOR.
>> I COULDN'T HAVE BEEN MORE
CLEAR WITH YOU ON THE PHONE.
I'M DONE WITH YOU, KEITH.
>> I KNOW, I KNOW, AND YOU
SHOULD BE DONE WITH THAT KEITH.
THAT KEITH DIDN'T DESERVE YOU.
BUT THIS KEITH?
THE KEITH I AM NOW?
HE DOES.
I'VE CHANGED, BABY.
TAKE ME BACK.
>> YOU'VE CHANGED?
HOW, KEITH?
HOW HAVE YOU CHANGED?
>> I QUIT DRINKING.
I HAVEN'T TOUCHED A DROP IN A
MONTH.
>> REALLY?
>> YEAH.
IT WAS HARD.
BUT I DID IT FOR YOU.
>> WELL, I'M GLAD.
>> AND NO MORE COCAINE.
>> WHAT?
>> I KNOW.
I NEVER THOUGHT I COULD KEEP
THAT INTO HIS EITHER BUT YOU
GAVE ME THE STRENGTH.
>> SORRY, YOU DID COKE?
>> JUST TO HELP GET ME OFF THE
BOOZE.
FOR A COUPLE OF YEARS BEFORE
THAT, TOO.
BUT THOSE THINGS ARE BEHIND ME.
NO ALCOHOL, NO COCAINE, NO
PILLS, I'M A NEW MAN.
>> GOD, KEITH.
PILLS TOO?
>> YEAH.
IT'S THAT SAME OLD STORY, YOU
KNOW?
YOU GO TO THE DOCTOR BECAUSE
YOU'RE IN PAIN, AND THEY GIVE
YOU THESE PILLS TO HELP.
BUT --
>> YOU GOT HOOKED.
>> EXACTLY.
THE NEXT THING I KNOW, I'M
TAKING FISTFULS OF VALTREX JUST
TO GET OUT OF THE BED IN THE
MORNING.
>> NO, VALTREX IS FOR HERPES,
KEITH.
DO YOU HAVE HERPES?
>> THE OLD KEITH DID, BUT THIS
KEITH, NO, HE'S GOOD.
>> NO, THAT'S NOT HOW HERPES
WORKS.
GOD, NOW I PROBABLY HAVE IT TOO.
>> OH, BABY, YOU'D KNOW IF YOU
HAD THE KIND I HAVE.
PLUS I ALWAYS USED PROTECTION
WHEN WE WERE TOGETHER.
>> YOU NEVER WORE A CONDOM.
>> BUT I ALWAYS HAD A GUN.
>> A GUN?
I'M GLAD YOU'RE GETTING YOUR
LIFE TOGETHER BUT WE'RE THROUGH.
>> HOW CAN YOU SAY THAT, BABY?
>> YOU JUST TOLD ME YOU HAVE
HERPES.
>> HAD.
PAST TENSE, BABY.
>> NO, NO, NO, NO, NO.
I DON'T EVEN KNOW WHY YOU WANT
TO GET BACK TOGETHER.
HALF THE TIME WE WERE DATING,
YOU WERE ROMANTICALLY CHECKED
OUT.
>> I KNOW.
BUT THAT'S BECAUSE -- AND THIS
IS HARD FOR ME TO SAY, BUT I HAD
GOTTEN A LITTLE TOO INTO PORN.
>> WOW.
THAT EXPLAINS A LOT.
>> YEAH.
IT'S ADDICTIVE.
IT SEEMS HARMLESS AT FIRST.
BUT THE NEXT THING YOU KNOW,
YOU'RE SHOOTING TWO, THREE
SCENES A DAY AND THERE'S NOTHING
LEFT IN THE TANK WHEN YOU GET
HOME.
>> I'M SORRY, YOU WERE DOING
PORN?
LIKE, HAVING SEX WITH WOMEN ON
THE INTERNET?
>> WHAT, NO?
NEVER.
>> THANK GOD.
>> NEVER WOMEN.
BABY, ALL THAT'S BEHIND ME NOW.
[ LAUGHTER ]
I'M NOT THAT STUPID BOY I WAS
BACK THEN.
I'M GROWN, I'M A MAN, I'M
18 NOW.
>> YOU'RE 18 NOW?
>> YEAH, I'VE CHANGED.
>> HOW OLD WERE YOU WHEN WE
STARTED DATING?
>> OLD ENOUGH TO KNOW I MESSED
UP.
>> OH MY GOD, I'M GOING TO JAIL.
>> BABY, DON'T WORRY ABOUT THAT.
EVEN IF THE COPS FOUND OUT, I
WOULDN'T SAY ANYTHING.
>> GOOD, BECAUSE --
>> I'D LET THE HARDWARE DO THE
TALKING.
>> PUT THAT THING AWAY!
>> YOU SOUND LIKE ALL THE PEOPLE
AT THE PLAYGROUND, PUT THAT
THING AWAY!
>> YOU TOOK A GUN OUT ON THE
PLAYGROUND?
>> GUN?
NO, NEVER A GUN.
>> WHAT THE HELL IS WRONG WITH
YOU?
>> PEOPLE AT THE PLAYGROUND SAID
THAT TOO.
>> KEITH!
>> ALL RIGHT, I'LL GO.
BUT FIRST, THERE'S SOMETHING I
SHOULD HAVE DONE A LONG TIME
AGO.
>> OH, MY GOD.
>> HAVE TO PRESS THAT EVERY HOUR
SO THEY KNOW I'M STILL WEARING
IT.
>> WHY DO YOU HAVE THAT, KEITH?
>> BECAUSE OF WHAT I TOOK OUT AT
THE PLAYGROUND.
>> RIGHT.
>> IT WAS MY PENIS.
>> YEAH, I GOT THAT.
>> LOOK, I KNOW I'M NOT PERFECT,
BUT YOU ARE.
AND I CAN'T LIVE MY LIFE WITHOUT
YOU, BABY.
PLEASE, TAKE ME BACK.
OH, CRAP!
HEY.
JUST HANG ON TO THIS FOR ME FOR
LIKE A DAY OR TWO.
THANKS.
YOU NEVER SAW ME, OKAY?
I WASN'T HERE.
LOVE YOU.
>> HE LOVES ME.